estamos ante el fin del gobierno de
boris johnson
es posible que este sea el fin del
gobierno de boris johnson pero va a ser
un fin muy lento pues es absolutamente
claro que ellos no está dispuesto a
renunciar y van a tener que forzarlo
para que salga del gobierno
bueno si el primer ministro no sigue el
consejo de parte de su gabinete de
dimitir al cargo tal como lo señala la
prensa local que otras herramientas
podrían tener los conservadores para
obligar la salida de johnson
la primera estrategia la veremos
desarrollarse de aquí al lunes cuando el
comité en 1922 que reúne a los
parlamentarios conservadores sin cargo
en el gabinete se reúna para intentar
cambiar sus reglas y llevar de esa
manera una nueva elección
que le permita a esos parlamentarios
establecer si mantienen o no su
confianza en boris johnson de darse un
voto de no confianza el primer ministro
éste tendría que renunciar bueno cómo
afecta a la insta institucionalidad
británica al que johnson se niega a
renunciar
ya le está afectando valentín a muchos
de los comités en donde se asienta el
poder político y legislativo en el
parlamento británico ya han cancelado
sus reuniones pues el número de
ministros y asesores que ha renunciado
supera las dos
docenas siendo es el caso tanto
y como el la renuncia del ministro de
irlanda del norte el ministro de salud y
el propio ministro de economía el
canciller se espera que el gobierno deje
de funcionar muy pronto y es éste el
elemento que mayor incertidumbre está
causando en el momento